[Music]
behind is interested in issues related to
the aeo of trust because with
today ubiquitous in our
daily lives and tend to become
ubiquitous in the history of the lia we have
already seen several periods
that we  called siffert there's no worse
times when ai was really seen
as a dead end
especially not to be funded
if it's now pretty much accepted that
technically lure still has things
to do  and therefore funding,
on the other hand, the next league winter
could well be societal and that is
why it is very important to
restore this notion of confidence in
relation to yesterday's program which
invades us today so
I  acceptability of the ai which is part
of the program trust x or y
how to do several things first
of all to be acceptable
the results of the ai must be robust,
that is to say that it can hardly be attacked
in a malicious way  easy or even
simply modified by various
and varied noises also obviously there is
the respect for privacy aspect it is
absolutely imperative that
we can guarantee that the ai will
respect privacy by respecting the
European legislation
finally and perhaps the most important
comes the problem of explains
empowered people tend not to
agree to delegate their decisions a
program a machine without knowing
exactly how it proceeds that's
why they don't laugh  is very
interested in participating in the
confidence program point
i indeed the solutions to the problem
do not explain equity of respect
for privacy would only take to
find by very upstream research which
then of course will go down to
higher ground  this can only
be achieved by a
virtuous loop between academics and
industrialists
the industrialist bringing the concrete problems the
academic bringing the
solutions  are also put concrete
[Music]